Action. Hi, I'm Rachel. Let's talk about Kimi's slides today.
A presentable slide stack need a clear structure, cohesive design, and often several runs of
editing. Kimi's slides can take care of the entire process, from early research to the
final edits. Give Kimi a topic and it can find relevant data. Dig into the research. It
can then organize everything into a clear and focused story, with a polish of a top consulting
firm. It helps us formatting too. Kimi can turn business data into polish charts,
map project mouse dough onto a timeline, or turn complex relationship into a smart
art. And nothing is locked in place. You can edit the data behind every charts, move
the shape around, and adjust individual notes and connectors in the smart art. You can set
the look and feel from the start. Choose one of Kimi's templates, or upload a PowerPoint,
image, or PDF as reference. Kimi will use the colors and layouts from a reference to keep
the new deck consistent with the brand. Of course, the first draft is really perfect.
You can keep improving it simply by talking to Kimi. Need to change a specific detail?
Leave a comment directly on the slide. Kimi will jump right in and make the change.
The new version history feature takes a record of every draft. If something does not work,
you can simply roll it back. Kimi can also rebuild complex technical diagrams.
Upload an image with PDF, and it can recognize the text, shapes, connectors, and formulas,
and recreate them as elements in PowerPoint can edit. Once you're finished, you can export
your work directly to PowerPoint and keep collaborating with your team. Kimi can also
create posters, infographics, and social media cards. And yes, everything is fully
editable. Open Kimi's slides now, bring your idea to life, and share them with your team.